isn't chuck really saying that because
of our brain chemistry and because of
what this plant can deliver to it that
god wanted us to get high from the
beginning
chuck isn't that really what you're
saying first of all how do you think we
got here god was high
[Music]
this is star talk sports edition i got
my reliable co-host chuck nice check
what's happening neil
all right chuck is a professional
stand-up comedian and actor and a sports
enthusiast though he's never actually
done sports in his life uh just the uh
enthusiasm
okay
rather than participants yeah exactly
but of course my other co-host has been
a professional athlete and still
announces soccer professionally did i
get that correct gary o'reilly
yes you did sir and who did you play for
in the uk um
okay uh tottenham hotspur if you're
familiar with them uh crystal palace
and brighton and hov albion which is
more of a mountain you could you
couldn't hold down a job with one team
i was so good they got rid of me at
least three times
so either they all wanted you or they
all didn't want you what
you could leave that one in history yeah
i had 14 years of being sacked by my
employees
[Laughter]
very good well
gary last year we did a show
on
sort of marijuana
and
some controversies with it related to
sports
and it looks like there's more to go on
that subject so what did you
what did you concoct for today
well
last year when
we got in a discussion with dr stacy
gruber our audience really loved it so
pun intended here it's high time
we visited the subject with the pot dock
and
and then once we've done that we'll open
it up to our audience's questions so
we've been out there and sort of
harvested their cosmic curiosity
and brought it to the show so it's a
partial cosmic queries i love it so it's
really driven by our audience so
everyone keep their eyes on the road um
the last time
we decided that world peace
depended on all of its leaders getting
high with chuck which i thought was
splendid in my classic classic british
understatement splendid idea it's such a
simple way to uh the answers are out
there is all i'm saying people
we learnt the marijuana legislation
is way behind scientific understanding
and data and so sort of pulling those
things together let's find out
at this particular point in time where
we are with dr gruber's cannabinoid
research and what other research in
medical science is taking place with cbd
and then
once we've tapped into that we'll
we'll throw ourselves into our audiences
like i said cosmic curiosity all right
right so that means we've got stacey
gruber once again stacy welcome back to
star talk thank you so nice to be back
actually excellent and i got your whole
cv here director of the cognitive and
clinical neuro imaging core at mclean
hospital's brain imaging center
but that's not enough you're also
associate professor of psychiatry at
harvard medical school and my favorite
acronym ever you direct mind
marijuana investigations for
neuroscientific discovery that's a clean
acronym you know most of them they got
they're tortured that one just flows i
tried that's cause somebody somebody was
high when they came up with
want a good acronym just you know take a
couple hits right
man what should we call this man
and i was thinking mine
right
right
so if only that were true but but you
know i i wish that we had the word
cannabis in the title instead of
marijuana because marijuana has such a
negative connotation to it right it's
really all about cannabis but then if
you try to go back then it's like mckeid
mcmahon like doesn't work so forget it
plus states have medical marijuana laws
so i figured we're safe and by the way
marijuana is only negative if you're
like old
you know
seriously there's nobody under the age
of 50 who hears marijuana and goes oh
dear my goodness i believe they're
talking about drugs
it's a drug isn't it
[Music]
it's literally a weed right so anyway so
so stacey who started calling you the
pot doc
you know i think that came uh from
something i did on cnn many years ago
the very first weed documentary called
weed on cnn that started sort of a whole
uh cycle or series of these things um i
was referred to as pot doc i think
sanjay said is it true your patients
call you pot doc and i actually told him
you know they call me lots of things
that is one of them i heard that chuck
she's on first name it's sanjay of
course yeah
yeah yeah yeah we all know we all know
yeah she calls him son
truth in fact i do not but i but yeah
let's be honest
our health care provider for for the the
country and the truth is he really did
raise the nation's consciousness about
cannabis or marijuana and well i think
the the cnn documentary wheat was the
very first one to really take an
in-depth look and it was supposed to be
when they talked to our hospital they
really were coming in to look at what we
had been spending you know at that point
more than two decades on looking at some
of the potential negative impact of
cannabis on the developing brain and
what happens if you're exposed early and
in high amounts and it very quickly
evolved into a different story about the
potential medical or therapeutic
applications of cannabis which we were
also getting involved with so it was
really a very different story and it was
the very first time the world well i
shouldn't say the world this this
country was introduced to the idea of
some of the non-intoxicating compounds
from the plant being used as therapy in
children like charlotte figgy for whom
charlotte's web is named the the sort of
famous uh uh very high cbd product that
allowed a little girl with an
intractable seizure disorder to live
seizure free uh which was rather amazing
so you guys pulled the wrestling reverse
is that what they call it in wrestling
the reverse
yeah the reverse is someone has has you
in a hold right and
if you just escape that's a one point
escape but in one maneuver you can flip
the situation
and then you're on top in control that's
actually worth two points that's more
valuable than just escaping yeah it's
it's called a reverse the weed reverse
reversal because they came after you to
try to you know a disparage marijuana
and then you guys turned it around it
was like look at all this good stuff it
does wait
wait wait i got a butt in wait
charlotte from charlotte's web this is
the story that has talking rats and
talking spiders
no oh very you know so interesting so
once again a bunch of young people would
not necessarily get that right so eb
white the the famous book good right
no no no so charlotte's web is a is a
um a strain of cannabis um that is noted
for its high cbd or cannabidiol content
which is non-intoxicating
and actually
the the way this goes and it makes you
see talking spiders this is what you're
gonna land on here
no no but as chuck very appropriately
pointed out the very first time we met
and i knew i liked him he said this
explains the talking snake in the garden
of eden right
okay
right there may not have been a fig leaf
covering their most private parts
uh charlotte figgy was a little girl uh
with an intractable seizure disorder
this this child was having
uh more than 200 seizures a week
their parents her parents she's one of
twins she was one of twins and her
parents were sort of at their end and
they had i think just signed a dnr which
must be heartbreaking for a five or six
year old child
and they you know do not resuscitate if
something happens exactly this was this
was and imagine being one of twins so
now you have a normally developing child
and you have this poor child
with gervais syndrome um which is an
intractable pediatric onset seizure
disorder which is devastating and they
were identical twins
identical twins so there's some risk to
the other twin i guess
but apparently she was okay and so um as
i understand and they are lovely people
and charlotte was uh a force um
they introduced this very high cbd
containing oil
the stanley brothers um from colorado
they they termed the the original chemo
bar the plant that that this was derived
from hippies disappointment very high
cbd containing combo not going to get
you high they made an oil they gave it
to charlotte and what happened was this
little girl went from having several
hundreds of seizures a week
to being almost seizure free and then
ultimately seizure-free for a very big
chunk of her life um unfortunately she
she died as a result of coveted related
um illness
yeah
2020 is very heartbreaking but this kid
went from she couldn't walk she couldn't
talk to having a normal child okay so
this is a modern story this is not some
old story okay sorry to take it down
this path
of talking spiders and rabbits right but
that's but they call this they call the
plant charlotte's web for charlotte
figgy which i think is really lovely
really beautiful really really beautiful
and and listen she will live forever her
life shines very brightly but but the
truth is this was the first time the
nation's sort of consciousness was
raised hey wait a minute maybe there's
something to this and of course many
people said wait a minute you're going
to give cannabis to get very very high
cbd very very low and sometimes in
certain cases no tease
cbd yeah right so so if people continue
to remember you that that's true you in
fact never die it's a form of
immortality to be remembered by loved
ones you've just proven neal
yeah yeah exactly so so what's your
latest research now you have a phd in
neuroscience so that means you're at it
you're you're busy you're a busy bee so
whose brains are you working on now we
try to keep busy so so you know we spent
a lot of time trying to come up with
novel approaches to different conditions
or or
um
disease states that plague people as
well as thinking about health and
wellness and
you know for what it's worth the mind
program hosts a lot of different studies
so we have the very first ever
longitudinal observational study of
people using cannabis for medical
purposes and we look at the way people
use real products in real world
situations and we look at what the
products are how they use when they use
and how they look over time not just a
week or two or three months six months
12 two years three years which is
amazing first data of its kind and we do
neural imaging okay just to be clear you
just described what longitudinal means
in a study
right because their longitude lines go
vertically on earth's surface and so
when you when you adopt that word for
one of these epidemiological studies or
direct study you're looking for its
effect sort of over time
rather than a latitudinal is that a word
in your world where you're looking at
everybody all at once
or cross-sectional studies exactly
social study okay just to make sure
just make sure everybody's speaking the
same language that's a great point i
think you can hear the word
longitudinal to me is sort of like
having a video a cross-sectional sort of
like a snapshot right
snapshot one moment in time if you were
like when they beep they each have their
value to the researcher right depending
on what questions are getting asked
absolutely and look acute administration
studies where you give people cannabis
of varying strengths and you know
different modes of administration have
utility i'm very interested in the
long-term effects what do people look
like in the real world using real things
for real conditions not what i come up
with in the lab but to that point we
have longitudinal observational studies
we have a bunch of cross-sectional
studies and we have clinical trials
where i make products designed or
optimized to treat different symptoms
based on the constituent that is the
sort of quote um ingredient profile of
the cannabinoids inherently so speaking
of that stacey when you're talking about
these ingredient profiles which but
chuck is just upset he wasn't in any of
your studies he's very upset about it no
no you don't you don't know it but uh
you're in my studies
so
so but what i what i'd like to know is
um
so every drug has a very particular
interaction with the brain chemically
and the resulting interaction causes
certain parts of the brain to light up
and do things
since we have cannabinoid receptors
we're just clear to
what does
what does thc
uh do what what's it actually doing and
what do these cannabinoid receptors how
do they play a part because you hear
people say that proves we should be
smoking weeds
right because we got those receptors so
we should be doing this
they say we're wired for weed right for
wheat come on man i'm wired for it if i
got these receptors so here's how it
goes so every mammal has what we call an
endocannabinoid system endo meaning it's
it's within us right it's our own system
a system just think of it this way
chemicals are receptors throughout the
brain and body
designed for
not outsider exogenous cannabinoids
necessarily but the things we make we
make our own cannabinoids
nandamide and the two most common that
we talk about are anandamide and 2he
let's just leave it there for a minute
but to your point about what happens
when you use cannabis so cannabis is
comprised of over 400 compounds over 100
of which are phytocannabinoids that is
they interact from the plant they
interact with our own endocannabinoid
system thc is the most common
that i think people know the most and
it's the primary psychoactive or
intoxicating constituent from the plant
thc has a very strong affinity that is
it binds pretty readily to cb1 and cb1
receptors throughout the brain we have
primarily two receptor types cb1 and cb2
chc and cb receptors are very friendly
they it binds pretty well um cb1
receptors throughout the brain cb2
primarily the periphery um in the gut
but that's what thc does the interesting
thing that we're just starting to find
out now is that things like cannabidiol
a primary but non-intoxicating
constituent from the plant touted for
its therapeutic potential doesn't bind
to cb1 or cb2 receptors it appears it
appears to modulate its effects through
different receptor types 5ht1a like
serotonin or trip or vanilloid receptors
really interesting so you can very
quickly begin to understand if you start
looking at these things why people
postulate that if you have more than one
of these cannabinoids
at play at once you might get a bigger
bank of the butt the so-called entourage
effect these things work together
synergistically to create
you know one plus one equals three if
you will it's you know the whole is
greater than the sum of its parts isn't
chuck really saying that because of our
brain chemistry and because of what this
plant can deliver to it that god wanted
us to get high from the beginning
chuck isn't that really what you're
saying first of all how do you think we
got here god was high
hey hey doctor i must ask you because i
think we're gonna we're gonna hit up on
a break shortly
the sort of rather 600 pound gorilla in
the medical room the last couple of
years has been covered
there must have been
some cbd research as to the potential
treatment for kovid and long covet now
is that something you ever got involved
in in terms of or aware of yeah
absolutely so um the idea that cbd and
other minor cannabinoids that in my mind
have a very major role
could help because cbd has been touted
as a tremendously effective
anti-inflammatory remember every day all
of us are dying of what oxidative stress
and inflammation that's basically what
we have every single day
long-haul syndrome or cova you know long
covert syndrome is characterized by sort
of a cytokine storm you know this
pro-inflammatory thing is there anything
we can do to sort of help dial that down
and there's been some really interesting
very compelling work but just to be
clear
the body continues to overreact that's
what's going on here is that a fair way
to put it
i i would say so and again that's not my
area of
my my area of expertise but it appears
so and it makes sense if you think about
it unfortunately you may feel better but
you may not really quote be all better
yet and some of the lingering effects
that i hear from people have nothing to
do with some of the things that they
suffered with and they actually have to
do with cognitive fogginess or you know
muscle muscle pain and achiness in
places and spaces they never had issues
before but you're right about the
inflammation um and this is anecdotal
and personal but i got coveted had a
very bad doubt with it and
for months
afterwards
had just um
um what would be presented as pureitis
or paritis which is just itching all
over your body no reason at all which is
an inflammatory response is what you're
talking about
yes and so if there's something we can
do to dial that down again i think of
these things as not switches but dials
right we want to dial it down just lower
it a little bit um cbd is a really
effective anti-inflammatory there are
some other ones but i think there's some
really compelling work that was
pre-clinical or basic work not in in
humans demonstrating that you can
actually modulate inflammation that way
so whether that translates or doesn't uh
personally we we have a project um
that we're about to submit for review
that looks at something let's just say
very similar to that um exactly that way
that hasn't been done before because it
harnesses not only certain cannabinoids
but other quasi cannabinoids um
g-coupled proteins that might be
harnessed to help yeah again these
things work better in the presence of
their friends if if you know what i mean
so you don't know stacy i could have
said that because when chuck says i had
anything and and the pot doc says let me
see what we can do for your condition
yes there's only one solution in there
like
let's get high let's see what happens
actually we got to take a quick break uh
when we come back more with the pot doc
dr stacy gruber we're going to finish
out some of what you've been up to and
then go straight over to our cosmic
queries uh because this is a hybrid
edition of star talk hybrid sports
edition
okay sorry there you go
when we return
we're back star talk sports edition this
is a hybrid cosmic queries and we've got
back on the show
stacey gruber the pop doc
she's affectionately known as and gary
was just getting the latest from her on
what her recent research has been into
this and you're going to tie it back to
a recent episode we had uh gary of the
new york giants football player who had
cro
chronic traumatic dramatic enceladus
it takes a few goes before anyone gets
it right
cte ct it doesn't roll off my tongue yet
so gary pick it up from there with
pleasure um
so doctor traumatic brain injuries tbis
or cte
and you as a neuroscientist
have you explored
the use of cbd as a treatment for this
sort of brain injury because we had
leonard martial on the formula giant and
he's an advocate for cbd he's personal
use
and then we can sort of link it back to
the genetic
profiling of
individuals to see predisposed to having
that being effective or not so effective
and before you before you hit that
stacey let me just ask as i understand
it cte
are physical
injuries to the brain
whereas everything you do is a
is chemical
so i guess we're not expecting the
chemistry to fix the brain to fix the
physical damage but can it possibly help
rewire it or lessen some of the symptoms
particularly the suicidal symptoms that
we know have arisen under those
conditions so if just spend a moment
just
contrasting
the the electrochemistry of the brain
versus physical damage
so you know i i tend to think of them as
as highly associated obviously so when
we have an injury um or
something happens to us we have a
cascade of events that happen right at
the cellular level um again they become
structural changes over time and one of
the greatest things about brain imaging
is that we can actually look at that
we can look at it
if we're really fortunate in people
before they ever have an injury and then
later
and even better look at it before they
die
in the living patient if you're if
you're really lucky that's right and
political studies have actually
demonstrated some unbelievably promising
uh outcome with things like cbd so if
you have a rodent population and
unfortunately
um you you give them head trauma all
right this this is how these studies go
so they
it's just it's just rodent football
right that's what
football well i mean
we know a lot and you administer cbd
before they ever had the injury
sustained the ones who had the cbd on
board before the injury recover faster
and have a
quote lesser degree of severity so
that's very wow
preemptive right so right so we think of
this as sort of the greatest
prophylactic that we could think of hey
maybe this is a preventative that we
want to utilize for our kids who are
stacy wants to get the entire nfl high
oh my gosh no no that's this this no no
no no no that doc i'm on your i'm on
your side of this let's be very clear
hold on
i'm out i'll get it okay so climb up
let's see what you did there
cbd won't get you hon um yeah i want to
make one thing super super clear so cbd
again as a prophylactic or um sort of
uh protective agent for individuals who
are about to let's say play sports great
thing um it's an antioxidant it's
anti-inflammatory
let me say this um these preclinical
studies are very promising we need more
human subject we're trying very hard to
get this quickly it's very expensive to
do
i just want to make one thing
absolutely clear purified cbd all on its
own is one thing most people take
products that are
uh um
either hemp derived or cannabis diet
that are high in cbd but that contain
other cannabinoids that said you can
have thc and other cannabinoids we
talked about this last time people can
unknowingly and unwittingly um be
positive on a drug screen never being
high never being intoxicated or impaired
but there's trace amounts of thc in the
product
so they pop positive on a urine screen
that said cbd can limit the severity and
extent of the injury it would appear
from these basic or pre-clinical studies
early studies
those studies need to get across the
line doc because this this isn't just an
nfl thing this this is across so many
different sports and you know you're
dealing with young people
who
could face a terrible terrible future so
yeah
yeah god speed with that i mean gary
gary among them right i mean yeah
totally and when we have a scenario
where we know there's a group that's
vulnerable to x or is already
experiencing why why wouldn't you try to
introduce something that we know won't
hurt but could very significantly help
so let me ask you this and i'm sorry if
i'm derailing this but i'm just sparked
what is the control and the variable
groups that because what you're kind of
doing is or do you just give it to
everybody and then study who's injured
chuck she's a scientist they have
control samples no but no but you have
to do that no my point is this you have
to get somebody hurt in order to know
how this works that's why god invented
rats okay
trials that's a great question and and
you know if you're not going to sort of
look at it in a preclinical model where
you can do these things although you
know not the greatest in animals what do
you do so you either pre-treat everybody
and those who sustain and you test
everybody and then you see how those who
are on something like cbd just sort of
as health and wellness do versus those
who weren't
uh that's one model there are a number
of different models that people are
using but to your point again the
pre-post control is important here um we
have i just got approval from the fda
for two
new clinical trials one is in patients
with glioblastoma so
the most devastating and fatal type of
brain cancer right is glioblastoma and
these people suffer terribly with with
terrible anxiety and pain what do you do
as a control group what do you do you
use standard of care so people who are
undergoing their normal treatment versus
those who are adding let's say my
product got it so that's the other thing
that you would do in this case so you
have let's say people who are athletes
typical standard of care they have their
regular regimen and everybody adds it
those who but everybody's assessed and
then those who sustain an injury you
look at those people over time you can
do that okay um that's that's one that's
one way
with patients with psychiatric
conditions because otherwise how do you
know
um but but it's a it's a really valid
question for sure sort of linking back
the genetical profiling because
some people will be predisposed and i
think you're doing some research in this
area and some people not so much to the
value and efficacy of cbd are we any
further ahead i'll probably rephrase
that are you any further ahead in that
research
because i haven't joined the team
i'm on the sideline now we're all family
are we the collective we the human
species i'd like to think of us as one
yes it's been the queen's jubilee we're
all we
right that's right
yeah i think we collectively are further
ahead in terms of our understanding with
regard to
the genetic liability for some people to
respond negatively to cannabis because
remember it's comprised of many
different compounds cbd is one
constituent one compound there are some
people for whom even small amounts of
thc are absolutely contraindicated
absolutely not
and it's not just your genetic liability
with regard to let's say a family
history for example of psychosis where
we would not necessarily want to
introduce a lot of thc
we also have our genetic profile in
terms of how well or how effectively and
efficiently we metabolize these things
if you're in a very rapid metabolizer of
thc versus a very slow metabolizer of
thc that's going to make a difference so
what we know about cbd thc and genetic
profiles is just now starting to to sort
of blossom we're getting there
but i will tell you this very very
important
many do not necessarily know or
appreciate the fact that cannabinoids
especially cbd and to a slightly lesser
extent but still to a significant degree
thc interact with the cytochrome p450
enzyme system our our liver's way of
processing drugs the reason that's
important we've all heard people say i
can't take this because i can't have
grapefruit juice because i'm taking this
drunk well that's because grapefruit
juice affects the way you metabolize
that drug it's the same for cbd and thc
so even if there's no other
contraindications what people are taking
what else people are taking is
incredibly important it is not
necessarily benign cbd can be incredibly
helpful and potentially harmful
depending on what other substances you
may be using i just want to make that
clear i didn't know people who
ate grapefruits had that accent that's
an interesting yeah
[Laughter]
you know i i very often don't believe
i've got some great fruit in my eye
why does it squirt like this
oh my god
all right let's get some questions for
you
build their group right so all right so
right so we got our patreon members who
in our in our up in our new model
uh they're the only ones who get to ask
questions for for just to give people a
little incentive to join join the the
community i don't want to call it a club
because that sounds so exclusive but the
community of people
all right
okay neil i'll get to some citrus-free
questions right this this is from all
clubs have british accents
so very good either come by and be a
part of
[Music]
all right gary all right here we go uh
pieto torrinsky i hope i've pronounced
it correctly is from poland and he's
thinking is this i've often heard about
people with a history of schizophrenia
in their family should never
try cannabis as it can trigger this this
disorder but could long-term use
trigger any mental disorders in healthy
individuals without such predispositions
and secondly has cannabis been
successfully used in any medical
treatment for reasons other than pain
relief and increasing appetite so
a few things to cover there doctor two
things to cover is right so first and
foremost great question and we were just
talking about this um the th so when we
talk about cannabis you know we tend to
use this one word but thc the main or
primary psychoactive constituent in the
plant can exacerbate psychosis and has
been postulated to perhaps create a
greater likelihood of having psychotic
type behaviors in healthy individuals
okay does it mean it causes psychosis it
may create a situation where you're more
likely to have these behaviors
especially if you have a history or
family history that's very very
important so the question was people
with the history of schizophrenia in
their family so that is what i call a
genetic liability or genetic
predisposition right and so for those
people we always say
be mindful of thc but interestingly and
very importantly cannabidiol sort of the
country cousin right to thc that is
non-intoxicating has been shown
potentially to help with things like
psychosis there have been a number of
studies that have demonstrated cbd is an
affected antipsychotic agent so what is
one to do you have to treat these
constituencies as individual
constitutional individuals
not just one thing right
i just say it's what every time you say
cannabidiol it sounds like you just made
up that word on the spot it just says
he and barney spent a lot of time in the
clearly
clearly but but to the other question um
about um successful treatment of other
medical conditions you know the
2017 the national academies of science
engineering and medicine put out a
report the health uh effects of cannabis
and cannabinoids and they they reviewed
i think ten thousand studies and found
evidence for what i call the big three
plus one chronic pain
nausea and vomiting is a function of
chemotherapy and muscle spasticity is a
function of ms
the equivalent plus one ms multiple
sclerosis multiple sclerosis yes sorry
the plus one was um intractable
pediatric onset seizure disorders so
seizure disorders that occur in
childhood things like lennox gaster
syndrome or dravet syndrome like uh
something strong with figgy suffered
from
cbd has been effective in treating that
in fact we have an fda approved
medication epidiolex that is
cannabidiol-based there are other
indications for cannabis and
cannabinoids that are that are certainly
promising but there's not quote
conclusive empirically sound data
just yet anxiety i would say is is
racing sort of to the finish line with
regard to
a potential impact of cbd certainly
seems to help with anxiety so gary what
else you got um woody's down in adelaide
i'm guessing that's australia
says does weed help or hinder recovery
and muscle growth
would the additional nutrition from
being able to consume five times as much
even be used so
i'm not sure about the second part of
the question no i i'm going to leave
that to you to answer or not as it were
does but but does cannabis help or
hinder hinder recovery muscle growth so
you know again some of the constituents
including cannabidiol
um have been shown to be tremendous
anti-inflammatory agents um and there's
a huge amount of neuroprotective and
potential analgesic effects of some of
the lesser-known cannabinoids including
cbd um
so so more broadly then not to put words
in your mouth but i think what you're
saying is so often inflammation in the
body
uh delays or inhibits your recovery from
whatever is going on so if you have
something that suppresses
your inflammatory immune system while it
doesn't explicit explicitly rebuild the
muscle tissue that you may be necessary
it helps your body to get there faster
is that a fair characterization i would
say that's very fair and what i was
actually just about to add
to to that point um is that
cbd cbc some of these other constituents
are clearly being used by athletes for
exactly this reason right because no
one's going to get in an ice bath
anymore i'm not sitting in there for 15
minutes give me something that works
quickly give me some chemistry right
yeah right okay uh but an answer that
definitely ca
that is applicable here is
it can't hurt
okay
but but also this is this is
non-steroidal anti-inflammatories wow
so yeah and to the extent that steroids
are or taboo we've got another path
around that let's take a quick break
when we come back more with the pot doc
dr stacy gruber in star talk sports
edition
we're back star talk sports edition all
about the latest on cannabis
and we touched on what roles it has
played and in recovery from injury in
sports or just in life
and and
how it's
suppressed seizures in the right dose
for the right
genetic profile so this is all really
good stuff stacy it's great to catch up
with you again on your work and the work
of your field and this is also
hybridized as a as a
uh cosmic queries so let's see how many
we can squeeze into this last third and
final segment let's see how tightly we
can roll this segment
let's do our best huh
alrighty alejandro renoso says chuck has
to say his name chuck has the same thing
alejandro
this is chuck's moment from where chuck
from monterrey mexico
what are the most common myths on
marijuana and what the actual science
says about it i think we've exploded the
last bit so what are the common myths
doctor we're just just that i mean i
want not just a regular myth give me the
biggest
the
biggest falsehood right that is just
just outright false that probably we've
heard
recounted in congress and people who are
otherwise under informed the top three
of those
three
um so who makes you like jazz music
oh that crazy music
so actually picking up on that uh and
like my posters behind me i think the
first myth is that everybody who uses
cannabis
uh will basically become some kind of a
drug induced it will enter some drug
induced fugue and never be themselves
again um the so-called reefer madness
sort of response right and in fact not
only do we not see just to be clear that
was the the basically public service
short film was it from the 1930s when
when was that made that's right 1937
yeah yeah
and it was quite potent at the time
right just freaking everybody out okay
so go on yeah it was um so i think that
that's probably um
one of if not the greatest myth right
then how about that it's a gateway drug
i was going to say that is number two um
and it turns out that kids who are using
cannabis are statistically more likely
to go on to use other drugs but that's
not because of the impact of cannabis
per se it's the same factors that drive
cannabis use perhaps
um drives them to look for other things
but it's not that marijuana quote paves
the way
um from a neural perspective right all
these things are rewarding we have
reward circuitry in the brain but that
doesn't mean there's been no conclusive
evidence that cannabis itself uh the
drug effects of cannabis are causally
linked to the subsequent misuse or abuse
of other drugs and what about addiction
um so
an addiction or misuse or dependence
it's certainly possible to develop a
problem um in the old days people said
you know somewhere around nine percent
of people who use cannabis are likely to
develop dependence that number has
jumped to about 30 in more recent years
my problem with those numbers is that
they're generally based on retrospective
survey data and not face-to-face
clinical interviews which of course are
the gold standard so um that also still
pales in comparison to other
substances typically so so um everybody
uses cannabis is going to become
dependent actually it's a relatively
small percentage although we want to be
mindful cannabis today is more potent
potency we typically use
we define as amount of thc higher thc
higher potency higher potency may lead
to a greater difficulty with the
substance so that's just something okay
so if you transported someone from the
1960s into the 21st century yes hey man
i got four joints let's smoke them this
is the wrong decision because they've
got
they had a that weak
cannabis in the 1960s relative to today
yeah somewhere somewhere um lower than
five or six percent thc and now the
national average thc is about eighteen
percent oh that's powerful that's
interesting smoke
holy smoke yes i knew what i was saying
just real quick so that's flower product
when we get to concentrates they start
life at 35 40 percent
they go north of 90 so for
people
that's that's a lot of tfc yeah that's
the difference between like a glass of
wine
and green alcohol everything yeah yeah
ever clear everywhere
and just one another quick thing because
it's highly informative stacy um can you
distinguish for me
uh a a dependence that's sort of
biochemical such as what we've known
happened with opioids and just you enjoy
it so much you just want to keep doing
it sure because you like it yeah and is
there a distinction between those two or
are they functionally the same
i think for many people they wind up
being the same so again we have neural
circuitry the reward circuitry that is
triggered when something feels good and
by the way your brain doesn't care
whether it's an opioid cannabis or sugar
doesn't care that's right it feels good
same quote areas light up if you will
give me some let's give me some more you
can give me some that's right your brain
on sugar looks a whole lot like your
brain on cocaine it is
right
but the truth is um in terms of cannabis
many people argue that you know you you
can't die uh from a cannabis overdose
there are no um cannabinoid receptors
for example on the brainstem you don't
stop breathing like you would perhaps
with opioids right or benzodiazepine
these are very important distinctions
and one last one i just want to hear
from the expert no one has ever gotten a
ticket speeding
while they were high on marijuana is
that correct
that's not correct that's not that's not
correct okay so what you're referring to
is people generally when they drink and
they think they're okay they hit the gas
and they move left on the highway when
they're using cannabis and they're aware
that they're a little altered they hit
the brake and they move to the right but
yeah okay what they really do is
demonstrate a fair amount of of lane
movement
often acute intoxication interestingly
interestingly uh when they're not
acutely intoxicated our medical patients
tend to look uh better
uh after using for a period of time than
before they started using whereas our
recreational or adult folks don't look
better it's kind of wow okay interesting
okay gary give me some more see i mean
we can squeeze into this section
um
question is about the way cannabis is
grown so here a little little zigzag on
the direction here
what determines whether it's sativa
indica or a hybrid does it need special
grow lights or maybe environment to give
the different types of highs
um thanks for the great work keep it up
you're welcome colt this doctor is
trying to get you to put him in business
growing me in his closet
so
stacy i had never heard this before is
there a distinction between the species
the subspecies of the plant and how it's
actually grown can how you grow and make
a difference there so really really
interesting question and you know in the
old days we talked about species of
cannabis um things that are closely
related but have different physical and
chemical characteristics
so called indica these kind of short fat
little plants that are sort of a body
high i feel sedate i feel chill i just
want to eat versus a sativa a tall
lenkier plant it's a sort of a in a head
high invigorating energizing
euphoriogenic really creative i want to
make i want to you know that kind of
thing um so these days we don't say
strange we say chemovol we say chemovar
chemical variety um
and
in fact it the thing that distinguishes
the two uh species is the fact that
they're they're different it's not how
you grow them they do grow differently
uh for example indigo grows more quickly
than a sativa
um
but but the thing that distinguishes
them is the fact that they are different
species most plants these days most
people who are experts at growing will
tell you almost
100
there's no such thing as a pure sativa
or pure indica anymore they're all
hybrids they are sativa heavy or indica
heavy but really hard to find a pure
example of either again what's their
favorite color light to grow in
uh so they have special uh special
spectrum lights to optimize the
flowering from the vegetative state
right it's very cool so
they're mimicking the sun i guess right
they mimic the sun but then they
actually have these ridiculous schedules
so the more light
they're exposed to the longer they're in
the vegetative state so they'll grow
taller and not flower when they flower
is when you harvest the flower is the
cool bounty that's the thing okay so
they don't necessarily live 24-hour
days
right i think that again this is again i
don't
i'm not a grower
uh and and let me give people ideas
about what to do and how to do it i
think when you want them to flower you
change the cycles it's like a 12 12 or
an 18 six um but yeah it's not 24. yeah
there you go dr dr gruber is a knower
not a grower
gary give me some more keep it going
right um from the artist formerly known
as james smith
right um says
is there one drug that will put you and
keep you in an altered state
and obviously if you answer that
question
that's going to make the artist formerly
known as james smith particularly happy
because they're probably going to go out
and grab some i see right um uh i don't
know of anything that will keep you that
has put you and keep you as in an
indeterminate period of time in a state
i think some people have had
tremendously long trips with lots of
hallucinogens um which are experiencing
resurgence popularity right now
and that's certainly one different from
cannabis for sure
for sure um i that's a great question um
yeah but i would i would say if it
creates a permanent state then you will
no longer know what it is to be high
right right right yeah
because you need the contrast between
the
high state and the non-high state that's
right it's like you can't have a
one-sided coin yeah right
is there is the good without an
understanding of evil right that's right
that's interesting that's also normally
called an addictive state because you
are doing the drug to be normal so if it
puts you
you know what i mean if if the drug
normalizes you drug normalizes you
you're just an addict now right right
okay but didn't he say that puts you and
keeps you in an altered state right so
yeah to your point so he would be walter
right no but to your point yeah it's a
good that's a great question because
where is the contrast if you're if
you're in an altered state you're no
longer altered it's just your state
right correct very philosophical point
there very deep right and guess
let me come back to you on that
um gary some more dylan
uh
i have many teenage friends who use such
drugs as pot and weed i thought they'd
be the same and i would like to know
more about the effects on the teenage
mind after many uses and are the dangers
we hear and see true or false i always
try to stop them with the idea that it's
bad but i need more to back up my claims
thank you all for the science you
provide to the public and the comedy so
chuck be up to you well thanks yeah but
you know what instead of teenage mind dr
gruber let's go with the developing
brain
yeah because that's really what it's
about yeah right so i would say that
during adolescence emerging adulthood
you know when when we're little uh the
brain is is vulnerable we're under
construction like i like to say to my
cannabis audiences are half-baked the
brain develops from the back to the
front and the bottom to the top and we
are not fully developed until
at least most likely our mid-20s uh so
it's important to know that by the way
the brain is vulnerable not just to
cannabis but to any substance anything
alcohol
the illness injury anything the brain is
under construction it's a vulnerable
substrate so
in general it's vulnerable but what we
know about cannabis is that early
exposure so our studies look at folks
before they're 16 versus those beyond
the age of 16 with regular use that
isn't you know four days five days a
week um what we know is that early
frequent and heavy exposure to cannabis
results in somebody looking slightly
different from those who don't use it
all for sure in fact most differences
that we see in recreational or adult
users come down to
uh the idea that there was early heavy
use versus not so much that's a reason
are they not as smart are they not as
social what's what is the symptom you
know interestingly we we look at um
remember i said the the brain develops
back to the front and bottom to top last
part of the brain to become developed is
the frontal cortex the frontal cortex is
critical for what we call executive
functions the ability to inhibit
inappropriate responses like man where's
this girl gonna stop talking like you
don't say that you're thinking it but
you don't say it oh or you know what not
to say in an elevator um it's also
it's also the first to go think of think
of the comparison between very little
kids old people right sorry uh dr gruber
the answer to that question is
excuse me that was me
all right no
i like the idea that we evolved to know
how to behave in an elevator which is a
20th century invention right right i
love that but but that frontal cortex
again being the last to come online
evolutionarily older parts of the brain
like your limbic system things that are
responsible for fight or flight making
sure you're fed and protected things
that keep what they call the reptilian
brain i guess right you've heard that
and they call it that because
evolutionarily speaking it's the oldest
we've had it forever keeps us alive um
the frontal cortex is the part that we
go you know i know this is a bad part of
town and he looks sketchy and i think i
see a knife but i'm gonna stay here
anyway no you know that that's we talk
ourselves
date him yes
i'm open-minded yeah
um listen i always say trust your gut um
but the deal is that part of the brain
is the last to become fully developed
and
when you expose you know an emerging
adult and adolescent to high amounts or
high potency or high frequency use of
cannabis there's a greater likelihood of
having difficulty with those types of
tasks that wind up being very important
in day-to-day living all right gary we
running really short on time here okay
pick a good one so amanda leininger has
asked this question um is there any real
proof of how much pot can help someone
with chronic
pain i mean mike goes on to say my mom
had lived with chronic pain in about the
last 20 years of life for multiple
surgeries and i hear through different
news stories about the possible ways it
helped control the pain better than the
prescription pain meds so
do we have sort of empirical research to
to back this up or are we still finding
our way forward again that first report
that nasa report um chronic pain was was
one of the big three and that was
primarily thc which is an effective
analgesic but remember there's different
kinds of pain there's there's
musculoskeletal pain there's neuropathic
pain different kinds of pain i would
also say that cbd because of its
anti-inflammatory effects
is also been shown perhaps to be helpful
with pain that's a really important
thing plus we do see studies
demonstrating reductions in the use of
conventional medications like opioids
like benzodiazepines in people who are
using medical cannabis we see this in
our study we see it in states with
legalized medical cannabis programs
fewer opioid prescriptions written very
very important so
it's very likely that for some uh maybe
a significant majority of people if they
find the right product or combination of
constituents they do get some relief
using are there
are there enough doctors who know to do
that or they just say i'll rather
operate on you and give you give you
opioids so
a great point and you know i hate to say
this i'm not even sure it's
that um
i'm not sure
i'm not sure even if they know if they'd
be willing to do it that's the thing i
think there's so much misinformation
about cannabis because again back to the
common myth if it's cannabis or
cannabinoids you must be getting high
and i always say no no you don't no not
at all right and this would be true even
in professional medical circles there's
there's misunderstandings of that you've
you've devoted your life to try to undo
i i certainly i have i have doubled down
on the efforts because the better that
our primary care and our specialty
physicians understand cannabis and
cannabinoids what they do what they
don't do what they couldn't do the
better they understand their patients
because of course if our patients are
using it we have a responsibility to
understand the whys and the what's and
the best how to's that's my job
so yeah so i'm going to land this plane
but let me
leave you with a thought stacey that if
you're getting this much
sort of career trajectory out of some
chemicals in a weed
how many plants out there are there
are
remain undiscovered simply because
we don't have enough people sitting down
hey let's smoke that hey let's smoke
this
is there
could there be an entire i mean it's got
to be okay wait to try hydrangea
very flowery uh yeah i think i think
there's huge potential in botanicals and
i think that we see that with some other
things primarily these days we hear
about it in the hallucinogenic space
like ayahuasca or i mean you know these
are other sort of natural things
mushrooms and there's tremendous
interest in terms of therapeutic
application
you know for what it's worth
documentaries of cannabis as medicine
goes back at least 2700 bc i was about
to say all you have to do
is go back in time people have been
getting high since people have been
people and since the garden of eden yeah
as we've established
all you gotta do is just go back in time
and
figure out what they were doing and man
but can we do that i mean it's not legal
if nobody's ever done it
but i mean it's not it's not illegal i
mean sorry if it's not illegal if it's
not on the books
so why can't we just go back and get
those drugs because they're written
about throughout antiquity and i think i
think we are i think we're seeing that
again cannabis was part of our
pharmacopia in 1850. you didn't need a
recommendation or certification to use
it doctors wrote prescriptions for it
for various thundery things it became
sort of outlawed much later as part of
the marijuana tax act and of course was
placed in the most restrictive class the
controlled substance act but the truth
is
we've been using it for thousands of
years and i maintain a lot of people use
it and they didn't get high the queen
people use it for lots of different
things we got to quit there
dr stacy it's been a delight to have you
now your third time that's a hat trick
on star talk uh and one of your earliest
appearances is when we were on nat geo
so that's great to have you back here
and stacey how can we find you on social
media uh i'm at dr stacy gruber uh on
twitter and i thought stacy with an ice
it's destined my mother had to be
difficult that's right she had to be she
had to mix up dr stacy gruber on
instagram and twitter and we have a
website which is i think just dr
stacygrouper.com you can read them
excellent
excellent can be part excellent and
chuck your chuck nice comic and gary
o'reilly my three left feet but tweeting
on on social media so it's been a
delight to revisit this subject thanks
gary for making that happen you're
welcome thank you thank our audience for
their questions yes yes these great
questions
yeah very good to our patreon supporters
there uh this has been star talk sports
edition a follow-up
on an earlier show on cannabis and its
infusion
uh overdue infusion into the health and
well-being
of civilization itself
neil degrasse tyson here as always
bidding you to keep looking up
[Music]